okay that's part of the trailer for the  new movie army of the dead  set in a post-apocalyptic las vegas  that the movie shows is filled with  zombies  so apparently a team of people take on  take on a job to  heist rob a casino trying to find a  hidden vault that's under the strip  filled with millions of dollars but  they have to fight their way through  zombie  showgirls and zombie elvis  impersonators oh boy it debuts in select  movie theaters  on may 14th then it'll be on netflix on  the 21st  is there one way or another that's  better than to see a movie like that do  you want to be in a big theater with a  bunch of people or do you want to be  in your house on the netflix i mean i  think it's the experience of the theater  nate give us your best impression there  it is there it is  thank you very much i like it  the zombie elephant oh my goodness nate  may 21st yeah he could spot him in the  bowtie  the classiest zombie there ever was